JLo's not just taking over the Super
Bowl in Miami but last night she gave us
the ultimate throwback with a rod on the
six in Manhattan that subway car was
recreated for the launch of her new
fragrance promise last night she also
revealed some Super Bowl secrets with
co-headliner Shakira we haven't even
talked about what exactly we're gonna do
that's gonna be the fun part now that
the announcements made we can talk if we
can get into the creative part of it
it'll be an exciting show that's what
you can expect I think of like kind of
like an explosion of fun and energy so
what surprises can we expect our et
source says more artists will be added
to the lineup and the NFL wants to make
it a celebration of Miami so we're
guessing there could be a cameo from
halftime veteran Gloria Estefan
[Music]
or even mr. worldwide pitbull himself
first recently
not only is pitbull from Miami but he
also has collaborated with both artists
no hints from jay-z he's the creative
force behind the show not gnomes in
those terms Shakira is on jay-z's Roc
Nation label and we're just hoping to
see her cute son and Sasha and Milan
front and center Sheeran on mama
they're the center of my universe I
never thought I would say this music is
my hobby
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]